euh on parle de livres jeunesse avec
Tiphaine qui est avec vous et avec nous
surtout un an après le déclenchement de
la guerre en Ukraine une guerre qui a
causé le départ de nombreuses habitants
vous avez choisi une sélection libre un
peu plus sérieuse qui parle de l'exil
avec des enfants contraints à l'exil
c'est ça qui fait notre choix
c'est Pascal mais vous allez le voir
et le premier un titre assez percutant
réfugié n'est pas mon nom c'est un livre
de Kate midner publié aux éditions La
Martinière Jeunesse et il s'agit d'une
maman qui prépare son enfant au départ
elle lui dit tu sais il va falloir
partir alors ce départ et bien c'est
l'occasion de préparer un sac mais un
sac que tu pourras porter alors ne
prends que que le nécessaire vraiment ce
que tu veux emporter et puis nous allons
beaucoup marcher peut-être qu'il n'y
aura pas de toilette nous serons
nombreux mais nous nous sentirons
peut-être un peu seul vous voyez Pascal
elle utilise des mots de maman des mots
très simples elle lui parle de ce qu'il
aime il y aura des camions des voitures
ne t'inquiète pas nous serons ensemble
mais on comprend à travers ces conseils
de maman ses conseils de la vie de tous
les jours que le voyage risque d'être
long et surtout les illustrations et
bien contredisent un peu cette douceur
dans les mots on voit le long voyage on
imagine que ça va être difficile et pour
le jeune lecteur et bien c'est un livre
assez émouvant mais en même temps qui
explique simplement ce que veut dire
l'exil et surtout elle dit à son petit
garçon tu sais à l'arrivée il y aura des
choses que tu ne comprendras pas mais
reste toi-même d'où le titre de ce livre
c'est vraiment un album que je conseille
pour expliquer aux enfants et bien ce
que c'est l'exil expliquer que et bien
ses enfants qui sont arrivés là et bien
ce sont des enfants comme tout le monde
je comprends votre émotion dans la voix
je vais vous laisser tranquillement
respirer un grand coup prendre la
position du lotus bleu pour vous
concentrer sur ma prochaine question qui
est aussi un peu sérieuse c'est vrai que
les enfants réfugiés arrivent parfois
seul dans le pays de destination et vous
nous avez trouvé deux auteurs canadiens
qui ont fait un roman graphique c'est
votre avant dernier coup de coeur oui et
c'est un roman pour les plus grands
cette fois à partir de 10 ans mais qui
est très sobre puisqu'il raconte ce
voyage des enfants qu'on appelle les
mineurs isolés vous savez il y en a en
France il y en a donc tous les pays il y
en a 400 à peu près qui arrive au Canada
et ce livre s'appelle bien simplement
seul c'est un livre de Paul Tom et
Mélanie béarger aux éditions la courte
échelle il raconte le parcours de trois
jeunes affines Alain et Patricia alors
il y en a un qui quitte l'Iran à cause
de la guerre à 14 ans et qui fait des
milliers de kilomètres avant d'arriver
au Canada il y a et bien Alain qui part
à 13 ans du Burundi parce que son père
est emprisonné et qui va mettre trois
ans à arriver au Canada et il y a
Patricia qui part à 16 ans alors vous le
voyez c'est un roman graphique donc il y
a et bien une histoire pas mal de textes
mais c'est écrit simplement et c'est
raconté par les adolescents et puis
cette illustré un petit peu comme un
récit de voyage donc c'est très agréable
à lire c'est vraiment passionnant
puisqu'on sait ce que ces trois jeunes
sont toujours dit devenus c'est adaptés
d'un documentaire je vous le conseille
c'est vraiment très très intéressant
Thomas dites-moi là on a en quelque
sorte des livres sur du support papier
vous-même vous faites des centaines de
productions des milliers de production
vous avez un CAT que ça se passe comment
alors notre travail pas avec des
catalogues parce qu'on a voulu de plus
en plus aller vers des produits
spécifiques et il y a dans dans le monde
du luxe de la créativité il y a une
espèce de raie qui n'est pas écrite qui
ont réinvente à chaque fois on va pas
s'amuser à refaire la même chose ça
serait trop simple c'est ça donc on aime
bien se faire la mienne donc voilà sans
doute que ça fait partie de l'image de
se dire que le vêtement ou le sac à main
que vous achetez n'existait pas et
n'existera plus et ça donne une unicité
aux produits et à la personne qui le
porte c'est tout et nous pour nous et
pour l'équipe que j'ai la chance
d'encadrer c'est c'est une passion parce
que ça veut dire que chaque produit doit
être réinventé donc on n'a jamais ce
petit moment de stabilité en se disant
que ce qu'on a fait va durer on doit en
perpétuellement se réinventer et c'est
ça qui fait notre le petit le petit côté
piment
ce qui explique aussi que dans la
bibliothèque de Tiphaine nous n'ayons
pas de catalogue regardez il y a que des
bouquins il y en a un tout dernier dans
votre bibliothèque c'est un roman qui
nous ramène en France Tiphaine
Marie d'ailleurs précisément et notre
héroïne s'appelle lulujah elle a fui la
Roumanie avec sa famille en espérant en
trouver un monde meilleur le livre
s'appelle la petite robe de Paris de
Pascal telede publié à la Joie de Lire
et finalement et bien il raconte le
quotidien un petit peu difficile de la
communauté Rome puisque il y a la
méfiance des habitants les campements en
guise de maison et la peur de la police
mais c'est un roman très amusant très
pétillant comme l'héroïne qui est assez
drôle et qui va vite démonter les a
priori de ses camarades je vous
conseille ce livre à partir de 10 ans
c'est vraiment drôle vraiment à partir
de voilà oui les enfants de fin de
primaire on va dire collège vous
découvrirez une petite fille qui va
finir par danser devant Notre-Dame avec
un petit air d'Esmeralda ça parle de
l'exil des difficultés mais aussi et
bien de la bonne humeur qui permet de
triompher et de se faire des amis pour
la vie super merci
ça me rappelle une chanson de Notre-Dame
de Paris belle talala vous étiez parti
là c'était une envolée lyrique